la lune c'est trop près je préfère
partir dans marche si possible faire du
tourisme dans l'espace un fantasme qui a
traversé les décennies
dès le début de la conquête spatiale
dans les années 50 certains imaginaient
déjà un petit week-end sur la lune
les voyageurs pour la lune en voiture
les touristes de sibérie le nez collé au
hublot dément la terre s'amenuiser puis
disparaître à la vitesse de huit ou dix
mille kilomètres tandis que la lune se
rapprochera à vue d'oeil
neuf ans plus tard en 1959 une agence de
voyages se refait déjà sur le business
du tourisme spatial
en attendant les évolutions de la
science les clients pouvaient préserver
leurs allers retours ont bien noté votre
demande d'inscription pour premier
voyage une aire est bien entendu que
leur tour y compris et je pas fait andré
stein est ingénieur de recherche faisait
partie des premiers français candidats
pour un voyage sur la lune
un projet ambitieux quel que soit le
prix mais le free de 16 millions nous
n'avons pas reculé mais non l'argent n'a
aucune importance
j'ai beaucoup d'amis sur qui je peux
compter pour m'avancer ces sommes et au
retour vous pensez je le rendrai
facilement j'ai déjà pris des contacts
et étant le premier français à l'est
dans la lune je vendrai facilement la
relation de mon voyage
dix ans plus tard le 21 juillet 1969
l'astronaute américain neil armstrong
faisait ses premiers pas sur la lune
un exploit qui redonnait espoir à
monsieur steinmetz
vous croyez que j'ai réalisé même sur le
plan scientifique
maintenant c'est réglé on commence à
prendre la chose au sérieux et lorsqu en
1979 des journalistes imaginait le
tourisme de l'an 2000 les vacances
spatiale était encore une fois une
évidence les plus chanceux et les plus
riches profiteront des navettes
spatiales pour visiter qui sait la lune
et mars sur le chemin du retour
l'hôtel de l'espace vous accueillera des
noces et des banquets s'y dérouleront
parfois aujourd'hui le tourisme spatial
n'est plus un rêve et fait partie des
réalités du 21e siècle
en 2001 le milliardaire américain dennis
tito devenait le premier touriste de
l'espace
après avoir déboursé 20 millions de
dollars depuis ils sont six à lui avoir
emboîté le pas
[Musique]